I definitely she's doing she's a tactile
access hole
it's an old tah between Jamie Lee Curtis
and David it's like begging for it I
feel like that is an immediate sign that
you two have made a horror movie
together brings you that close wait cuz
hold it do that to me right now but you
don't have one she won't do it we
haven't made a horror movie together can
you fix this we'll work on this
Halloween we just need something sharp
to cut the seam get it can we get Jamie
Lee Curtis a knife of some kind
that's probably an unwisely actually you
know what that's what I should come out
with on QVC a collection that know why
someone has not come to me there's
cutlery I'm telling you QVC wait for it
that will be soon I would buy that in a
sec I love it well because like that's
your thing when I look at you I'm like
she gonna mess some people up yeah it's
how I wake up in the morning I'm just
you you know me so well I look I love
that this version of Halloween like what
we've seen is busting apart all these
mythologies that we've lived with for so
many years of our lives and that you are
sitting here at the center of this like
really taking charge of some [ __ ] and
selling cutlery on QVC yes in your own
name
yes you know what we actually all we did
or all David and Danny and Jeff did is
they just took scissors to the
appendages and cut them free it was not
to dismantle them or discredit them or
come up with anything that was
disparaging in fact we put a lot of like
Easter Egg homage as to the other films
too but that the idea was in order to
tell a story that takes place 40 years
later you have to go to the original
story and then jump it forward 40 years
and I think that was the brilliance of
just their concept was let's honor those
other films people may have their
favorites we aren't going to focus on
them we're going to focus on one story
that happened
forty years ago and tell a story of what
happened to those people forty years
later well that's what pumps me up as a
fan because I feel like we've seen a lot
of films recently that are made by fans
who happened to also be really talented
filmmakers and then it just opens up a
whole new world so I'm reading like this
is the final chapter like everybody's
making a big deal they say Final when I
read about it but it's saying
I mean I've nobody's seen it I know and
I've read it on that you know which
makes it true question mark are we
opening this up to a whole new kind of
era of Michael Myers a universe if you
will anything is possible
what we were trying to do is is
reestablish a group of characters in a
place and as in a series of events that
I loved and had great nostalgia for and
and begin that exploration and
dissection a little bit we had a blast
from you know from day one and we're you
know getting very close to being
finished with the film now so you know
who knows where we go from here Jamie
Lee Curtis finding tactile access holes
a dream come true
come on yeah do you think over the years
that Laurie Strode has learned anything
from Michael Myers besides maybe the
obvious of violent tendencies so all
jokes aside because I take it maybe way
too seriously and I I think we approach
I mean the approach was with a lot of
integrity this was not nobody got paid
it was the same as the first movie
people made this movie made it because
they wanted to be a part of it they
wanted to work with David they loved the
script they loved what we were trying to
do but the entire crew and the actors
really went into with a lot of integrity
so what I would say it's a movie about
trauma it's a perfect movie for 2018 you
guys were so prescient in understanding
that for such a long time Laurie Strode
has been the only person and Haddonfield
Illinois saying Michael Meyers is coming
back Michael Meyers is coming back to
the point where she lost her
husbands she lost her child 1978 there
was no trauma help for her she had to
exist on her own and what we find 40
years later is a woman who has been
dogmatic saying this man is coming back
this man is coming back to the point
where everybody thinks she's crazy it's
the boy who cried wolf right it's the
woman who cried Michael Myers but the
integrity of it is that all of that
trauma is coming out in this movie
because she has been preparing for this
for 40 years and I just get power from
this trailer like when I watch you in
this I think a reimagining of Laurie
Strode almost or like just this continue
it's the same girl without any mental
health help for 40 years carrying the
weight of this attack on her I get I get
empowerment but you see there is you can
only get empowerment because the other
option is to be a victim and to be a
victim means you have no life at least
she's fighting for the chance to have a
life to protect her family and it's
emotional it isn't it with all the jokes
aside if it's yeah it's deep yeah the
trauma is deep and I think the result
and the what would use the confrontation
that occurs cathartic kind of right the
idea is to take a very stressful
situation that by today's standards is
seemingly from a headline standpoint
kind of insignificant but then take the
the personal approach to something that
I do feel is is universal well because
that's what makes it meaningful but
that's what makes it scary but that's
what made the first movie meaningful was
it was a small town these were regular
girls and you focused on this one young
girl who had dreams of finding a
boyfriend all of the natural
vulnerabilities of a young girl and you
put her in the path of Michael Myers and
it naturally creates this incredible
feeling of wanting to protect her being
terrified for her
and now in the same breath you have at
my granddaughter who's the innocent my
daughter who wants nothing to do with me
because all I was was this dogmatic
woman and you bring Michael Myers back
into it and it's again as terrifying in
this cathartic as the original movie
simple clean beautiful storytelling and
also Nick Castle I know is and of course
we've known I mean I've known Nick for a
very long time and he was John
Carpenter's best friend who've been in
film school with him was a director in
his own right and John was like I need
somebody to be the mask I need somebody
to be the shape and Nick was like okay
and you know Nick had two small children
at the time and you know they're in a
band together so it was interesting to
have him come back and reprise the shape
whoo it feels feels good to us the rules
like the Royal us of the fans I'm like
yes I speak for all of us were so pumped
and the trip I don't even know like I
get so excited when I think about the
trailer with this seemingly like crazy
chess game that's going on that's like
has Michael Myers standing there and I'm
like please don't show him the mask I
just showed him the mask like great how
scared are we going to be be very scared
of me yeah yeah well that's the thing is
like what Jamie said poor foundation of
drama relatable characters add just
enough humor to keep us with enough
tension breaker and and give us some
great graphic visuals and of course John
Carpenter's doing the music so that's
going to be huge and and and you know
it's a childhood dream for me
[Music]
[Applause]